What I'd like to do today
is go back very briefly so
we're all on the same page,
moving from events in 1964
through 1966 actually.
I'm trying to compress some
information so we can really
be ready to catch next week
right where we should
be. Remember in the last
lecture, I talked about the
events leading up to this
pivotal summer
of 1964, John F.
Kennedy's assassination,
Lyndon Baines Johnson taking
up the mantle of
Kennedy's civil rights
legis--legislation, the
battles over the civil
rights bill, a bill
being essentially stuck in
Congress, especially
the Senate filibuster,
student leaders from SNCC
conceptualizing the idea for
a Freedom Summer, freedom
vote to train people how to
become--how to fully embrace
their rights as citizens in
the state of Mississippi,
setting up freedom schools.
These things all come
together in the summer of
1964. Students from
all around the country,
Yale included, travel
down to various points in
Mississippi to begin
Mississippi Freedom
Democratic--Mississippi,
Mississippi Freedom Summer,
set up freedom schools, help
organize votes to create a,
a separate delegation to the
Mississippi Democratic--to
represent the Mississippi,
Mississippi Democratic Party
at the Democratic National
Convention in August. And
the day after Mississippi
Freedom Summer begins,
three of the
workers, Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney,
disappear and are very
quickly presumed to have
been murdered. During the
course of the summer, the
Civil Rights Act of '60--the
Civil Rights Act is
passed, signed into law,
the most comprehensive
law in support of racial
equality in the nation's
history. There was an
immediate white backlash.
George Wallace declares,
the governor of Alabama,
declares his candidacy.
Ultimately has strong
showings in Wisconsin,
Indiana, and Maryland.
Public places in the South
go private in order to
prevent integration. Civil
Rights Act had not addressed
the private institutions.
It's a long summer of riots
in 1964. Riots aren't just
in southern U.S. In fact,
they're largely urban and
northern: New York
City; Rochester;
Paterson, New
Jersey; Elizabeth,
New Jersey; Philadelphia;
Chicago. It's a time of
trial. And as you'll recall
from my lecture on Monday as
I was wrapping it up,
weeks before the Democratic
National
Convention convenes,
the bodies of Schwerner,
Goodman and Chaney are
found, August 4th. And
they become martyrs of the
movement, there's no
doubt about it. It's really
important that you know
that they were found in
Philadelphia, Mississippi,
for reasons that become very
important later on in
this course. The bodies are
found in an earthen
dam in Philadelphia,
Mississippi. There was
an aspiration to have them
buried together, but
Mississippi state law said
the races had to be buried
in separate spaces. David
Dennis, the head of
CORE in Mississippi,
agrees to give a eulogy
in honor of James Chaney,
the sole African
American of these,
of these three people
who were murdered. And he
agrees to do it and then
he sits down to do it and
something happens.
I want to play for
you a clip. It's a
three-minute-long clip.
It's a little bit longer
than I normally
like to play,
but you'll actually see the
transformation happen during
the course of the eulogy.
August 7th, 1964. The
funeral of James Chaney in
Meridien, Mississippi.
I feel that he's got his
freedom and we're still
fighting for it.
But what I want to talk
about right now is the
living dead that we have
right among our midst,
not only in the
state of Mississippi,
but throughout the nation.
Those are the
people who don't care,
those who do care but don't
have the guts enough to sign
up for it, and those
people who are busy up in
Washington and other places
using my freedom and my life
to play politics with.
That includes the President
on down to the governor of
the state of Mississippi.
In my opinion,
as I stand here,
I not only blame the people
who pulled the trigger or
did the beating or dug
the hole with the shovel,
I bury the people--not bury,
I'm sorry--but I blame the
people in Washington, D.C.,
and on down in the state of
Mississippi for what
happened just as much as I
blame those who
pulled the trigger.
You see, I know
what's going to happen.
I feel that even if they
find the people who killed
those guys in
the summertime,
you got to come back to
the state of Mississippi and
have a jury, of
all their cousins,
their aunts, their uncles.
And I know what
they're going to say,
'not guilty' because no one
saw them pull the trigger.
I'm tired of that.
See, another thing that
makes me even tireder,
though, that is the fact
that we as people here in
the state and the
country are allowing this to
continue to happen,
even us as black folk.
So I look at the
young kids here,
that's something else
that I grieve about.
And little Ben Chaney here
and the other ones like him
around in this audience.
Well if you want someone
to babysit for your kids,
hire a black mammy
to hold your baby.
And as long as
he can do that,
he can sit down beside me,
he can watch me go up there
and register to vote, and he
can watch me take some type
of power in this state and
he can sit down as I rule
over him just as he's
ruled over me for years.
This is our country, too.
We didn't ask to come here;
they brought us over here.
It's cut off at
the last bit there,
but he simply reiterates,
"this is our country too."
Asked about this
eulogy afterwards,
Dave Dennis said he looked
down--he was planning to
abide by the rules and
give sort of a calming and
reassuring, mournful
and certainly angry,
but in a polite sort of way,
mournful eulogy. And he
looked down at Ben
Chaney and he just snapped,
"because I can't do this
any longer." What you see
happening in '64 and you'll
see more in '65 as well,
is a fundamental shift in
the tone of the movement.
This is really one of the
most important things to
understand about this moment
in the movement's history.
You also see in the wake
of great triumphs of the
movement, like the
Civil Rights Act being
signed--there's no mistaking
it's a triumph--you also see
a very clear tactical
shift in the movement,
and that's what this
lecture really is about,
the fundamental tone and
tactical changes in the
movement that
happened in the,
in the '64, '65 moment.
From the standpoint of
tactics, it's clear
to Johnson and to
others--Lyndon Johnson and
to others--that by signing
in the Civil Rights Act,
he was kissing away the
Democratic Party in
the South. This is the,
this is the real fear. And
the only Democrats who were
going to vote for him were
African American Democrats.
From the highest levels
of political government,
organized
government, the notion is,
"you've got to get these
black folks registered."
Well, as it happened--at
least for the Democratic
Party. On the ground,
that's the agenda as well
for people in Mississippi,
people who were working on
Mississippi Freedom Summer
and the Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party.
So the Freedom--MFDP,
Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party,
an attempt by white
and black activists in
Mississippi, with
support from other places,
to set up a slate of
candidates to run as the
alternate to the Mississippi
Democratic delegation,
that would
ultimately be seated at the,
at the Democratic National
Convention. The vice chair
of the MFDP, a very famous
activist named Fannie Lou
Hamer. Fannie Lou Hamer
was the youngest of twenty
children, sharecropper
all of her life,
no education after
the third grade,
but had powerful presence,
incredibly eloquent,
captivating
speaker. And sadly,
part of what made her so
captivating is the story she
had to tell was
nightmarish. When I say
that, you know, she was in
school to the third grade,
the schools were only open
for three or four months,
because the rest of the
time you were working in the
fields. Well, as other SNCC
activists and SCLC activists
come to, to Mississippi,
they meet this person
they've been
hearing about, Ms. Hamer,
and she begins to be
inspired by them and starts
to try to organize voters on
her own. She's harassed by
the police. People would
call all day and night on
her home telephone number
to the point she had to just
take the phone off the
receiver. Threats with her
losing her job,
threats against her life,
but she's unfazed.
The Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party is
more than just her,
but she embodies so much of
it. As they're marching to
the Democratic
National Convention,
the debate is which
Democratic delegation will
the national Democratic
leadership accept? MFDP
insists that they're
going to be the party to be
recognized. Democratic
established leadership said,
"That's just not going
to happen." Southern
delegations in other states
threaten to walk if Lyndon
Johnson, Democratic National
Committee admit or--yeah,
admit--MFDP to the floor of
the convention. Johnson's
already afraid of losing
the South and now this is
confirmation. And these
were states that are already
leaning towards
Barry Goldwater anyway,
the Republican
candidate. Anyway,
the convention arrives and
Fannie Lou Hamer goes to the
credentials committee,
representing the MFDP,
and starts to talk with them
about why the MFDP needs to
be recognized as the proper
delegation. This is the
committee that's setting the
rules for the conference,
for the convention. And
her statement is captured on
live TV. This is
when you'd have what,
what is it
called? Gavel-to-gavel
cover--coverage of
conventions and such. And
she starts telling a
story about her efforts to
organize people to exercise
their full civil rights just
to vote, get them
to register to vote,
and being
arrested by the police,
being taken to jail. And
while she's in jail for
breaking no law, they
put--the jailors stand by
and get two black inmates,
bring them over and threaten
them with further punishment
if they did not beat Fannie
Lou Hamer, and they beat her
senseless. She survives the
beating, she survives
it, but is physically,
permanently damaged from the
beating. This is what being
a citizen meant if you're an
African American activist in
Mississippi. You could
end up like James Chaney,
could be beaten to an inch
of your life like Fannie Lou
Hamer, certainly sending
signals to the rest of black
Mississippians. Well,
while Hamer is giving this
testimony to the
credentials committee,
Lyndon Johnson,
still in Washington,
D.C., at the White
House, hears about it,
knows it's going out
live and is furious,
and immediately
calls a press conference
trying--[student sneezes]
Bless you--trying to simply
distract the media from
what's now airing over the
country. Just a trumped-up
news conference. He had
nothing to actually talk
about. A lot of the cameras
stay with Hamer, but Johnson
recognizes that he's losing
grip of retaining any, any
hope of keeping the white
South. He asks
his vice president,
Hubert Humphrey, to get
Walter Mondale to coordinate
this, a
resolution to a dispute,
and the resolution says that
the Mississippi--Mississippi
delegation, the
Democratic delegation,
Democratic Party would
be seated if they swore
allegiance to Johnson's
civil rights platform.
But--And in
addition to that,
two delegates from
the Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party would
also join the Mississippi
Democratic delegation. All
but three of the Mississippi
Democratic Party delegates,
the "formally" elected
delegates--this
is an all-white,
all-white party
in Mississippi,
I should have said in the
beginning--all but three of
the Mississippi
delegates bolt,
and the MFDP refuses to
compromise. "You either
seat all of us or none of
us." The Democratic Party
National Convention
ultimately recognizes just
three of the delegates
from Mississippi who didn't
leave. The rest of the
Mississippi delegation votes
for Barry
Goldwater. The MF--the,
the Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party delegates
ultimately vote for LBJ.
There's no logical
choice, frankly,
between LBJ or Goldwater,
as far as their actions were
concerned.
Johnson, of course,
goes ahead and
gets re-elected,
or gets elected, I guess,
for the first time in a
landslide, but he loses five
states in his native South.
The states that were
threatening to bolt if he
caved in to the MFDP came
through. He might have lost
them anyway, but
it becomes very,
very clear to
Johnson at this point,
to any Democratic activist,
that the black vote is now
critical in the South, if
there's any hope to hang
onto a Democratic presence.
So this is the end of the
summer in 1964. Civil
Rights Act is there,
but the question of the vote
is unresolved. Civil Rights
Act does not address
voting. Right away,
activists on the ground and
those at the highest reaches
of the federal government,
Democratic Party at least,
hone in on voting.
This is the next,
this is the next
challenge. Meanwhile,
Martin Luther King is
awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize. He goes to
Oslo to receive it,
and he returns in January of
'65 to participate in this
next wave of challenges, the
vote. He goes--In January
of '65 he goes to
Selma, Alabama,
Dallas County,
and he announces a new
SCLC initiative to register
people to vote. The
sheriff in the county,
a guy named James
Clark, was much like--oh my
goodness--our favorite
punch--punching bag from
Birmingham.
Bull Connor.
Ah, you guys were paying
attention. Thank you,
Bull Connor--much like
Bull Connor. So he's,
he's pulling
out cattle prods,
clubs and tear gas to break
up crowds. I mean he is
ripe for becoming a target
of national media coverage.
The situation in
Selma is really quite
astonishing--in,
in Dallas County,
I should say, not
Selma. The larger district.
In Dallas County, out of
fifteen thousand people who
are registered to vote,
only three hundred and
thirty-five of them are
black. Now if you don't
know Alabama, it's
important to understand,
it is a state
with, in many places,
a majority black population,
and in all places,
a significant black
population. So in Dallas
County, there is no
black voting presence.
In Alabama in general,
seventy-seven percent,
over three quarters
of eligible blacks,
are still off the voting
rolls. It's a much higher
percentage than what
you see in other places,
other southern--throughout
the South in general. So
King goes down there
to announce a new voter
registration drive, knowing
that the sheriff would be
one he could bait
pretty easily. Rallies are
organized, marches
are planned. Middle of
February, peaceful SCLC
rally in a neighboring,
neighboring area was
attacked by the police. The
city police, the county
police and the state police.
And during the melee, one of
the people involved in the
rally, a twenty-six-year-old
named Jimmie Lee Jackson,
according to witnesses,
shields his mother who's in
the process of getting
beaten by a state trooper,
and he's shot in the stomach
and dies. Now the police
account of what
happened is different,
as one would expect, but
the fact of the matter is,
he's shot in the
stomach, and he dies.
Guaranteeing--I mean this
would be horrible enough as
it is, and one would
hope gather attention,
but what guaranteed
gathering the attention to
this fact is that
news cameras were there.
And in the, in the confusion
of the rally being broken up
by the police, several
reporters from NBC are
injured.
Essentially attacked,
hit--they get beaten up
by the police as well.
Guarantees national
coverage. A plan evolves
immediately to
march from Selma,
where Jimmie Lee
Jackson was murdered,
from Selma to Montgomery,
the state capital,
fifty miles away. The
original plan was to take
Jimmie Lee's body along this
path and leave him at the
state house stairs.
And, very quickly,
saner heads prevail.
This is disrespectful to the
body, of course. But the
fact is the plan for a march
from Selma to Montgomery
is hatched. On March 7th,
the chairman of the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee, John
Lewis, begins a march
across--begins the march
from Selma to Montgomery.
He's leading in
single file order,
maybe two or three across,
six hundred protesters over
the Edmund Pettus Bridge.
It's very important to know
that Martin Luther
King was not there,
even though he knows about
the plans. This is the
march.
Waiting on the other side
were Alabama state troopers,
under orders from
Governor Wallace to stop the
marchers.
Oh, I hit it a second too
late. You can see right
here in the fading
out, that's John Lewis,
now
Representative John Lewis,
in the tan trench coat.
Clark's posse was
on the sideline.
It will be detrimental to
your safety to continue this
march and I'm saying
that this is an unlawful
assembly. You are to
disperse. You are ordered
to disperse. Go home or go
to your church. This march
will not continue.
Is that clear to you?
I've got nothing
further to say to you...
Tear gas canisters.
The march, the
disruption of the march,
is captured on
live TV, of course,
and shown across the nation,
leading people to ask the
same question that Fannie
Lou Hamer asked when she was
giving her testimony to the
credentials committee: "is
this America?" Thousands
flocked to Selma as a
protest was announced,
"We will march again" from
across the
country, black, white,
doesn't matter. They all
come to Selma to right this
injustice. This day becomes
known as "Bloody Sunday."
Two days later,
King is there,
and they're going to march a
second time. And this is a
pattern that has grown to
become quite irritating to a
lot of activists
on the ground,
is that King, for all of
his incredible charisma and
power, is never
right--really quite there at
the moment of crisis.
His presence creates a new
moment of crisis,
no doubt about it,
but he wasn't there getting
beaten on Bloody Sunday.
And this is a tension
that has been there in the
movement for years already,
that when King arrives,
the cameras show
up; when he leaves,
the cameras
leave. In this case,
the cameras were already
there. There's a federal
order banning the march,
wanting a cool-down period.
King goes, "We're going to
have a march anyway." A
bold statement.
So on Tuesday,
March 9th, King leads a much
larger group of activists
across the Edmund Pettus
Bridge and starts the march
to Montgomery. This is not
the famous march though.
Crosses the bridge, the
police are there like they
were the last time. They
tell him to turn around,
the same script. "Go
back to your churches" and
whatnot. King asks, asks
his followers to kneel and
pray along with
him and then,
in a complete shock to those
SNCC leaders who are still
beaten and bloody
from two days earlier,
King tells them to go back
to their churches. This is
not what they had bargained
for. They were going to
press forward and do
this all over again. More
horrified to discover that
King had negotiated--to keep
the peace and
respect the federal order,
King had quietly negotiated
this whole performance,
so the police knew that if
King stuck to his script,
he would kneel and
tell his flock to pray,
you know, create
the visual moment,
and then disperse
peacefully. SNCC leaders
had no idea about this.
They--so King came in and
took their
march, hijacked it,
turned it into his circus,
and then they didn't even
get to press forward to
honor Jimmie Lee Jackson's
life. This is a very
important moment in the
movement. Not one that
is--it's not triumphed as
the march, the eventual
march to Montgomery that
happens two weeks later,
under incredible federal
protection by the way. The
slight cracks and fractures
and fissures that were
there between SNCC and
SCLC--remember SNCC
being organized under SCLC's
umbrella just five years
ago at that point--the,
the cracks are now wide
open. And SNCC would no
longer see itself as being
part of SCLC's organizing
logic. And SNCC would no
longer kowtow to King's
declarations. They are
truly--it is truly its own
organization, and
as we'll soon see,
takes off on its own path.
So the march does proceed
in--on the
21st. What's that,
forty-five years ago and
a, and a few days. But the
real drama in many ways,
for the movement's sake,
is the drama that happens
in the two attempts prior to
that. So the issue is
voting registration. This
is what these rallies were
about that where Jimmie Lee
Jackson had been murdered.
This is what the vote to
Montgomery is, is all about
recognizing the fact that
African Americans still
don't have access to the
ballot box. Meanwhile,
a voting rights bill is
bouncing around Congress,
and Lyndon Johnson keeps
upping the stakes, and, and
in many ways throwing his
presidency in harm's way.
He declares between the
Tuesday turnaround march
and the eventual march,
he goes to joint session
of Congress and astonishes
Congress by quoting one
of the famous lines of the
movement. He
says, you know,
he's basically
saying, "As a nation,
we cannot abide by treating
our own citizens this way.
Their struggle is our
struggle and we shall
overcome." It's an
astonishing moment,
presidential rhetoric,
Lyndon Johnson saying it.
In June of the
same year, '65,
at Howard University's
graduate--graduation
ceremony, Howard
being the most important,
largest historically black
college and university,
essentially mostly funded
by the federal government,
Johnson at the graduation
ceremony says the following:
"You do not--[coughs] excuse
me--You do not wipe away the
scars of
centuries by saying,
'Now you are free to
go where you want,
do as you desire, and choose
the leaders you please.' You
do not take a man
who, for years,
has been hobbled by
chains, liberate him,
bring him up to the starting
line of a race saying,
'You are free to
compete with all the others,
and still believe that you
have been completely fair.
This is the next and the
more profound stage of the
battle for civil rights.
We seek not just
freedom, but opportunity;
not just legal
equity, but human ability;
not just equality as
a right and a theory,
but equality as a
fact and as a result."
This is part of LBJ rolling
out affirmative action,
sort of testing the waters
essentially. But very
quickly, affirmative action
policies now become woven
into federal
policies as well. In fact,
women who have been the
greatest beneficiaries of
affirmative action,
something I'll probably say
again in about
three or four weeks,
were not covered under
the original umbrella of
affirmative action. It
was actually only added two
years later and added by
someone who was hostile to
the whole idea. He
thought, "My god,
if we just add
women to this thing,
we'll sink the
whole program,
and people went along
with it. He's like,
"Oh, I misjudged
that one."Anyway,
back to the summer of '65,
Johnson is going out on a
limb, essentially, making
clear he is going to be the
civil rights presidency;
now he's a president,
president, and many
other things as well,
but he's definitely the
civil rights president. On
August 6th of 1965, he
signs the Voting Rights Act,
an incredible effort to get
it through. And the Voting
Rights Act prohibited states
from imposing literacy
requirements as obstacles
for accessing the ballot
box. It's the most
successful way of cutting
out the vote. And,
most importantly,
and this is the most
important element,
it allowed the attorney
general to send federal
examiners in, into any
election where they thought
voting rights might be
curtailed.The Voting Rights
Act, just to make clear--and
some of you may get--I mean
I get, I get this
email about once a year,
or once every other year,
that the Voting Rights Act
is coming up before Congress
and it's going--they might
not approve it, and they'll
end the right to vote for
African Americans. My
father sent it to me once,
which drove me
crazy. I'm like,
"Dad, you know better
than this." The fact is,
the Voting Rights Act does
not give anybody the right
to vote. It gives the
federal government the
authority to protect the
right to vote. It brings
into bold relief the federal
government's ability and
right to supersede
in local affairs,
which has been
the, the nut of the,
the bone of contention since
the Voting Rights Act was
passed. The
Voting Rights Act has,
if you look forward from
the moment of its passage in
August '65, makes a clear
change. Within four years
of its passage, three-fifths
of adult blacks are
registered to vote. It's an
astonishing shift. Between
1964 and '69, roughly the
same period we're talking
about here, the number of
registered black voters goes
from, in Alabama, less
than twenty percent of the
population to over sixty
percent of the population.
In Mississippi, it goes to
less than seven percent of
the population to
over two-thirds of the
population, within five
years. It's a seismic
shift, especially when you
consider the number--the
numbers we're talking about
in terms of the African
American population. So
there's no disputing the
fact the Voting
Rights Act has a,
a, a significant
effect, as you look forward,
the crystal
ball, three or four,
five years from the moment
of its signing. It's also
clear the Voting Rights Act
had astonishingly no effect
in the immediate moment, in
those places where blacks
already had the
right to vote.
And this was
made very clear,
five days later, when
the Watts community in Los
Angeles goes up in flames.
A few words about Watts.
It's a riot in the, if you
know Los Angeles demography,
in a portion of the city
that is due south of central
Los Angeles, a place that
had been the home for the
longest, for, for a couple
of decades in the wake of
the Second Great
Migration, World War II,
where black Los Angeles was
overwhelmingly found. It
was not a wealthy
part of the city,
not by any stretch. But
people had the kinds of
civil rights, citizenship
rights they wouldn't have
had, African Americans,
they wouldn't have had in
Mississippi or Alabama or
Georgia. They also had,
visually, a better quality
of life than those people
who are stuck in high-rise
slums in Chicago and New
York City. There's
green spaces. There's,
well maybe
they're not homeowners,
but their homes, were living
in homes. They aren't in
high-rises, certainly.
There's sunshine,
for goodness' sakes,
there's palm trees.
But the fact is, there
is incredible economic
degradation, powerful
sense of hopelessness,
and a real feeling that
you were not a citizen,
even though you could, could
vote. But it really had no
great benefit to
you. So in Watts,
the flashpoint revolves
around an arrest that goes
bad. Marquette Frye, an
African American man living
in that neighborhood, is
stopped by the California
Highway Patrol at night.
He'd been drinking with his
older brother. Cops pulled
him over and they're about
to let him go, when
another--this is Marquette
Frye's version--when another
more belligerent crew of
California Highway Patrol
officers arrive. Frye's
mother arrives, wanting
to know what's going on,
trying to get her son. And
these new belligerent cops
assault the mother. Frye is
hit by a police officer as
he is trying to
protect his mother,
thrown into a police
car, sent off. The police
version is rather
different. Drunken driver,
they pull Frye over,
radio for assistance.
Other police arrive.
Meanwhile, a crowd arrives
of citizens and residents of
the area. Marquette Frye
makes a play for one of the
police officers' guns, and
they start wrestling with
him, throw him
in a car. And,
immediately, the crowd
that's gathered around,
a crowd that had been worn
out by police brutality,
historic police
brutality in that area,
city, the crowd starts to
explode. What happens,
ultimately, is that
thirty-four people die the
next handful of days.
Over a thousand people are
injured; four
thousand are arrested;
property damage in excess
of two hundred million,
which was a ton of money in
1965 if you think about it;
damage ranging
across a forty-six mile,
square mile area,
larger than Manhattan or San
Francisco. Thirty-five
thousand adults are deemed,
quote, active rioters.
Seventy-two thousand are
deemed close
spectators. And what,
why this is important in the
reports that follow is that
the police are going in
intermittently. It's just
one big logistics mess.
Police are going in now and
again to try to calm things
down. The riot would be
sporadic. There'd be
a hot point over here,
a fire would be
started over there,
or a fake fire
alarm would be called,
and police would go over
there. The fire department
would be called to
a scene and then,
and then they'd be showered
with bottles and bricks and
then snipers. It was an
urban battle zone. So a lot
of people were active
as rioters who never,
you know, see justice,
according to the police,
because they're the ones
shooting from windows the
police can never get to,
for instance. Ultimately,
sixteen thousand
National Guard,
LAPD, and California Highway
Patrol officers are brought
in. They militarize
the zone in order to
re-establish the peace.
It's a massive property
riot. Food,
stores that sell food,
liquor stores,
furniture stores,
clothing stores
are destroyed,
especially those owned by
middle- and upper-class
whites. Churches, homes
and libraries are relatively
untouched.
And I say this just to--you
know some people will talk
about whites--Watts as a
mindless insurrection. I'm
not defending the riot
at any--to any extent,
but it wasn't mindless.
Certainly something tactical
by going after those
institutions that the
residents thought were
keeping them down. Store
owners who were
black would write up,
you know, "soul brother"
in their window to prevent
their store from being
attacked. Now some of them
got attacked anyway, because
there's certainly going to
be some level of chaos in
any kind of riot. But often
they were passed
over. For white America,
all of this happens
completely out of the blue.
After all, Lyndon Baines
Johnson has just signed in
the Voting Rights Act.
"What else do you people
want?"
is essentially the
mentality. "What else could
you want?" And what L.A.
shows is that there are deep
and fundamental problems,
that the civil
rights movement,
as far as its most
famous rhetoric,
you know, the right
to vote, you know,
the right to go, go into
the front door of a bus--a
restaurant, ride in a bus
where you want to--L.A.
had all those things
already. It didn't point to
more fundamental economic
problems. That's what Watts
was about. Now Watts, now
whether the riot--I'm not
going to play counterfactual
history: would the riot have
happened if this or
that hadn't happened? I,
I don't know. But what is
clear is that just as people
are struggling with this
new tactical change in the
movement, got to
pursue the black vote,
people are clearly
struggling with a shift in
tone. The kind of militancy
and armed militancy that you
see happening in Watts is
becoming more recognizable
and more frequent. Part
of it grows out of the
rhetoric, no
doubt, of Malcolm X,
even after he disavowed a
lot of the rhetoric. This
becomes very clear in next
week's reading. And part of
it is--part of it's growing
out of an increasing U.S.
military occupation in this
strange place they haven't
quite figured out
yet called Vietnam,
and people coming home from
Vietnam with a different
sense of how to
pursue justice. There's a
fundamental shift in tone
and you see it embodied in
Watts, profound impatience.
Now impatience is not just
an urban or western and
northern phenomenon. It's
an impatience that's in
the, in the heart of,
quote, "the
movement" as well,
in the southeastern
United States. Blacks are
increasingly unhappy about,
or impatient and frustrated
with, the client-patron
relationship in the South,
and throughout the country
really. And we'll see,
we'll see next week, when
we start talking about the
Black Panther Party, how
it becomes articulated in
Oakland, California.
It's most famously the Black
Panther Party. But it's
important to take a moment
to talk about the first
Black Panther Party in the
context of shift and
tones. [computer beeps] Oh,
that's my--I have
something happening soon,
I guess, my computer telling
me I have to go. So let's
look at the first
Black Panther Party.
You have the march
from Selma to Montgomery,
the, the famous march.
So much of the political
rhetoric talks about
how--or historical rhetoric,
it goes off without a
hitch, incredible federal
protection. But a hallmark
to how great we are as a
country because of how
peaceful it was. It wasn't
so peaceful to everybody.
One of the activists who
came down to
Selma to help out,
a woman named Vi--Viola
Liuzzo from Michigan,
her job was working support
for the march. And her job
was to, in her car, ferry
people back from Montgomery,
from Montgomery back to
Selma. She happens to be
driving her car with
some of the marchers in it,
driving through
Lowndes County,
Alabama. A car
pulls up next to her,
rolls down the window,
pulls out a shotgun,
blows her away.A young man
named Stokely Carmichael,
northerner raised in
the, in New York City,
graduated from
Howard University,
goes down to participate
in the Freedom Summer,
rises to the leadership
circle in the Student
Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee,
he's sent--Stokely
Carmichael is sent to
Lowndes County to figure out
what the heck is going on in
this place. Trying to
organize the black vote,
partly in honor of Liuzzo's
assassination. What he
finds in Lowndes is a
population that is a
predominantly
black population,
eighty-one percent black.
It's a black county. Black
citizens of
Lowndes were poor,
they were landless, and
economically dependent on a
small, white, elite planter
society. It's apartheid.
Blacks outnumbered
whites overwhelmingly,
eighty-one percent, but they
were not registered to vote,
and they actually feared
civil rights agitation.
It's like, "What are you
doing coming in here? Our
life is horrible, but you're
going to get us killed." As
Carmichael digs a
little deeper in Lowndes,
he finds, finds a
different current though,
and he just discovers that
trying to register black
Lowndes County citizens to
vote in the Democratic Party
is something he's really not
going to have much success
doing. There's such
hostility and such
hopelessness. But he
also discovers a level of
militancy there as well. So
they form their own party,
the Lowndes County
Freedom Organization,
the LCFO. The
Lowndes County Freedom
Organization. And it has as
its goal running candidates,
developing a platform,
becoming a recognized party,
an alternative to
the Democratic Party,
which had no relevance to
black Mississippians living
in Lowndes County. And the
LCFO chooses as its mascot
the black panther.
And the logic was,
LCFO leaders talked about
the black panther as an
animal that retreats
when it's pursued,
until it's
backed into a corner,
and then it springs forth
with a life or death battle
on its mind. And that's how
the Lowndes County farmers,
they're all farmers,
felt. And importantly,
they were armed. I mean,
and this is no big deal. I
mean, farmers in the South,
everybody was armed. You
shot your meals often.
The party was armed, and it
was uninterested in working
with whites.
Whites who sympathized,
who wanted to help
them, it's like,
"No, forget it."
And this group,
as we'll see next week,
becomes the inspiration for
the famous Black Panther
Party. Now very quickly,
by this point,
'65, SNCC had,
you know, is
breaking apart from SCLC.
It becomes
affiliated with the,
sort of the rising New
Left, the radical student
organizations. It's
exploring other ideological
options, instead its, its
of what was then certainly
radical in 1960, you know,
integrating lunch counters,
integrating places of, of,
of commerce. SNCC links up
with the Students for
Democratic Society,
SDS, for a while, but the
racial politics become too
complex, because SNCC
leaders felt the whites were
trying to take
control of SDS,
black leaders in SNCC.
In January of
1966, Samuel Younge,
a twenty-year-old Navy
vet, African American,
recruited by SNCC to be
an organizer in Tuskegee,
he's killed for using a
white bathroom. At that
point, SNCC comes out
against the war in Vietnam
and, in doing so, isolates
itself from mainstream civil
rights organizations.
Another major break in the
fabric, rip in the fabric.
In the wake of this, the
Atlanta cell within SNCC,
which is
increase--increasingly
radical, starts getting
racially restless. In the
spring of '66,
Stokely Carmichael,
essentially now
the leader of SNCC,
produces a position
paper that says: "White
participation, as
practiced in the past,
is now obsolete. If we
are to proceed toward true
liberation, we must cut
ourselves off from white
people. We must form
our own institutions,
write our own histories."
"White participation, as
practiced in the past,
is now obsolete." Stokely
Carmichael is now the chair
of SNCC. Whites are now
kicked out of the movement.
I'm going to
stop right there,
but we are
literally, quite literally,
at the cusp of the
famous articulation of Black
Power. Certainly all the
pieces are now in place,
and the movement, the famous
movement that we've all been
taught about in our little
grade books and stuff,
begins its very quick
descent into completely
splintering apart. Those
are the events from '64 to
'66. We'll pick
up from there,
at there on Monday.